Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Juventus Turin steht zum zweiten Mal innerhalb von drei Jahren im Champions League-Finale und das obwohl man das Herzstück seines Spiels verloren hat in den letzten Jahren. Warum eigentlich? Ich spreche darüber mit Christian Bernhard, freiem Sportjournalisten. Christian, ich grüße dich.
Hallo Max, grüß dich. Schön dich zu hören.
Du bist ja einer meiner Lieblings Italien-Experten, bist tief verwurzelt. Wir haben schon in unserer gemeinsamen Zeit bei Spox viel über italienischen Fußball gesprochen. Und jetzt müssen wir über Juventus Turin sprechen. Da möchtest du mir sicher nicht widersprechen.
Nee, sehr gerne machen wir das. Auf jeden Fall.
Ich fasse mal so kurz zusammen, warum es diesen Kurzpass hier braucht, meiner Meinung nach. Juventus Turin hat verloren. Pogba, Morata in dieser Saison und in der letzten Saison, Vidal und Pirlo. Man nenne mir eine Mannschaft, der das Herz ihres Spiels ähnlich entrissen wurde. Und trotzdem sind sie jetzt zum sechstmal Infolgemeister geworden, zum dritten Mal hintereinander die Coppa Italia gewonnen und stehen zum zweiten Mal innerhalb von drei Jahren im Champions League-Finale. Christian, das musst du mir erklären.
Das hast du eigentlich sehr schön zusammengefasst. Genau, das ist wahrscheinlich von außen erstmal auch gar nicht so einfach zu verstehen, aber wenn man ein bisschen tiefer reingeht, dann glaube ich, kann man zumindest Ansätze dafür liefern und einer der größten Ansätze – wir können ja gerne gleich schon ein bisschen mit beteiligt anfangen – liegt halt wirklich in dieser Planung, in dieser Kaderplanung, die Juve jetzt in den letzten Jahren einfach vorangetrieben hat und wir kommen ja danach dann auch noch auf die einzelnen Spieler klar, aber es ist vielleicht gar nicht verkehrt, wenn man da mit einem Namen anfängt, den vielleicht so viele in Deutschland nicht unbedingt auf dem Zettel haben, aber das ist halt der Herr Marotta und das ist der Generaldirektor, in dem Fall Sportdirektor, der wirklich seit sieben Jahren jetzt mittlerweile bei Juve ist, der zusammen mit Andrea Agnelli, mit dem neuen jungen Präsidenten gekommen ist und die haben es wirklich in den letzten Jahren geschafft, genau das, was du gerade gesagt hast, obwohl die immer wieder sehr schwerwiegende Sportliche Abgänge hatten, haben die es trotzdem geschafft, nebenbei so ein. Sie haben ja mit Pjanic und Higuain einfach zwei Leute geholt. Higuain war halt einfach genau dieser Mann vorne drin, dieser starke Mann, der ihnen gefehlt hat, obwohl Morata logischerweise das auch überragend gemacht hat, aber bei Morata war ja die Geschichte auch eine andere, den hätten sie ja sehr gerne behalten, aber da war halt einfach diese Rückkaufklausel von Real, da konnten sie nichts machen. Und Pjanic und Kedira, wenn man Kedira noch dazunimmt, haben einfach wirklich es geschafft, genau das, was du gesagt hast, dieses Loch, das Vidal und Pirlo, ja, gerissen haben, trotzdem irgendwie aufzufangen, das haben die logischerweise nicht alleine geschafft, sondern weil die in eine Mannschaft reingekommen sind, die auch ohne diese einzelnen krassen Namen mit Vidal und so trotzdem schon sehr gut funktioniert hat. Und jetzt, wenn man sich das dieses Jahr anschaut, waren das wahrscheinlich im Nachhinein diese Puzzlestücke, die anscheinend davor, trotz der anderen großen Namen, die schon da waren, trotzdem ein bisschen gefehlt haben.
Trotzdem würde ich sagen, also Sportdirektor, wichtig, das muss ja fast so sein, also wenn man Pirlo verliert und den irgendwie ersetzen kann, wenn ich mir anschaue, wie Juventus Turin auf dem Transfermarkt agiert, dann sehe ich immer wieder punktuell teure Verstärkungen in dieser Saison, Pjanic und Higuain, und ich sehe aber auch wahnsinnig viele Leihspieler. Also ich kann gar nicht zählen, wie viele es sind. Kannst du mir kurz erklären, was ist die Systematik und der Sinn hinter dem, dass Juve, ich würde jetzt mal grob überschlagen sagen, Minimum 20 Spieler, wahrscheinlich eher 30, wenn ich durchzählen würde, verleiht?
Also das Prinzip, das dahinter ist, das ist in Italien, das muss man jetzt auch schauen, mittlerweile ein bisschen am Aussterben. Also es gab bis vor kurzem immer noch, da war Italien, glaube ich, mit das letzte Land, oder die Spanier hatten so etwas Ähnliches, noch Vertragswerke, wo sozusagen zwei Spieler zu gleichen Teilen zwei Vereinen gehört haben. Sozusagen Mannschaft A hatte 50 Prozent der Rechte an einem Spieler und Mannschaft B hatte 50 Prozent der Rechte. Dieses Konstrukt wurde jetzt letztes Jahr abgeschafft, also es gibt es jetzt so in dieser Weise nicht mehr, aber das muss man wissen, um zu verstehen, dass eben viele italienische Vereine oder gerade die großen italienischen Vereine, und das war in den letzten Jahrzehnten eigentlich immer gang und gäbe, die haben versucht, sich einfach, sei es Juwe, sei es Milan Inter Roma, die großen einfach proaktiv sozusagen schon mal, gerade was die jungen italienischen Spieler betrifft, viele dieser jungen Talente oder von denen man glaubte, die könnten in den nächsten Jahren was Großes werden, sich einfach mal präventiv zu sichern, die dann aber weiterhin auch gerne, und das nicht nur ein Jahr, also jetzt nicht vielleicht wie bei Lahm damals in Stuttgart oder wie bei Alaba in Hoffenheim, nicht nur die ein Jahr auszuleiten, sondern die im Prinzip vielleicht schon mit 19 zu kaufen und dann aber erst mal sogar drei, vier Jahre lang beobachten, wie die sich sozusagen in der Fremde machen, sprich bei kleineren Vereinen, teilweise sogar bei Zweitligisten, aber im Hinterkopf immer haben, wir haben ja noch Rechte an denen Ich bin sehr gespannt, was du mir da so sagen wirst. Wenn du das mit einigen Jungen machst, dann funktioniert das logischerweise nicht mit allen. Also da werden einige darunter sein, die einfach diesen Sprung zu so einem Top-Team einfach nicht schaffen. Aber du hast halt vielleicht unter 10 halt auch 2, 3, die wirklich das Potenzial haben. Das beste Beispiel bei Juve ist zum Beispiel Claudio Marquiseau, der jetzt auch schon ewig dabei ist, der ein Juve-Urgestern ist. Aber bei dem ging das am Anfang auch so los. Also der Kamas der Jugend wurde dann aber auch sogar zwei Jahre an Empoli weitergegeben. Es wurden Rechte auch teilweise an Empoli abgegeben, weil logischerweise auch die kleineren Clubs sagen, reine Ausbildungsvereine wollen wir auch nicht sein. Also im Sinn von ihr leidet uns die und wenn die gut sind, dann müssen wir sie euch wieder zurückschicken. Sondern wir wollen da schon auch ein gewisses Investment daran haben. Und wenn der Wert des Spielers dann sozusagen in dieser Zeit bei dem kleineren Verein steigt, dann muss Juve in dem Moment dann auch einen etwas höheren Preis zahlen, um ihn wieder komplett zurückzuholen. Und das ist dann sozusagen der Nutzen, den auch die kleinen Vereine haben. Und dieses Prinzip hat Juve auch in den letzten Jahren immer wieder. Auch jetzt zum Beispiel, sie haben im Winter einen sehr jungen Innenverteidiger von Atalanta, die einfach eine richtig gute Saison spielen, für Matija Kaldara. Den haben sie auch einfach jetzt sich schon mal gesichert. Lassen ihn aber auf jeden Fall nächstes Jahr noch im Bergamo, vielleicht sogar auch noch zwei Jahre, weil sie einfach sagen, es ist uns lieber, die Jungs spielen woanders, sammeln Spielpraxis. Und wenn wir aber sehen, dass die eben das Zeug haben, um bei uns eventuell dann wirklich auch mithalten zu können, Und wenn wir aber sehen, dass die eben das Zeug haben, um bei uns eventuell dann wirklich auch mithalten zu können, dann holen wir sie zu uns und dann bauen wir sie da auf. dann holen wir sie zu uns und dann bauen wir sie da auf. Und daher kommt auch diese hohe Zahl einfach an. Gerade jungen Spieler, die einfach wirklich gerade bei Juve, die werden quer über den Stiefel verliehen. Also, es gibt in jeder zweiten Serie B-Mannschaft in Italien, Also, es gibt in jeder zweiten Serie B-Mannschaft in Italien, gibt es junge Juve-Talente, die da einfach spielen und die da ihre ersten Schritte machen. die da einfach spielen und die da ihre ersten Schritte machen. Und dann im Idealfall vielleicht irgendwann mal zu Turin stoßen.
Und dennoch ist das erste, woran man bei Juventus Turin denkt, nicht nur wegen des Spitzennamens Alte Dame, eher nicht das junge Talent, sondern die alten Recken. Du hast vorhin schon ein paar Namen aufgezählt. Gianluigi Buffon, hinten drin im Tor, Bonucci, Gelini, Vasali. Das sind richtige Granten. Auch Semmike Dira kann man langsam dazuzählen, auch wenn das so eine andere fußballerische Koleur ist. Kannst du mir kurz erklären, wie ist das Korsett der Mannschaft, das du auch schon angesprochen hast, aufgebaut? Von hinten nach vorne und nimmt dann die Routine nach vorne ab? Nein, kann man ja auch nicht sagen, wenn vorne equal in stürmt.
Also im Prinzip kann man das Rückgrat relativ einfach – das geht ja auch fast – von hinten nach vorne benennen. Das ist logisch angefangen bei Buffon, der logisch seit dem Abgang von Pirlo einfach noch wichtiger geworden ist, weil davor waren es Buffon und Pirlo, sowohl sportlich aber auch von der Erfahrung und auch von dieser Aura sozusagen. Und deswegen war auch zum Beispiel die Präsenz von Buffon seit dem Pirlo-Abgang noch mal wichtiger, weil er einfach nicht nur sportlich einfach so wichtig ist, sondern wirklich auch, was man ja auch sehr oft an der italienischen Nationalmannschaft sieht, einfach von seinem Wesen, von seiner Aura. Also es berichten viele auch Kedierer, auch große Namen, die zu Juve kamen, die sagen, als wir dann in die Kabine reinkommen, dann siehst du diesen Buffon da. Also da schauen sogar gestandene, sag ich mal, Weltklasse-Spieler einfach zu dieser Aura auf, die im Umgebt. Und logisch der Anfangspunkt, dann ist eben genau die drei Verteidiger, wie du gesagt hast. Muss man auch ein bisschen trennen. Barzali und Chiellini sind jetzt logischerweise schon mittlerweile. Grad Barzali ist jetzt 35, der ist logisch, da geht es Richtung Ende. Bei Chiellini finde ich, der ist im Prinzip, wenn man sich es anschaut, gleich alt wie Philipp Lahm. Also das ist jetzt nicht so, dass das ein, ich glaube, bei vielen im Kopf ist, der auch so gefühlt 5, 6, 37 ist aber gar nicht. Der ist einfach auch schon ewig dabei. Ist aber, würde ich sagen, für einen Innenverteidiger mit 32 oder 33, kann man glaube ich schon eben noch sehr, sehr gute Leistungen bringen. Und Bonucci ist ja sowieso erst und Anführungszeichen 30. Also würde ich sagen im besten Alter sozusagen. Das ist logischerweise die Vierer-Torhüter-Abwehrstruktur, auf der alles aufbaut. Und dann ist, wenn man jetzt noch, lasst mal das Sportliche kurz hinten nach, dann ist eben Marquise noch einer dieser Senatoren, wie in Italien halt oft genannt werden. Also einfach, das ist die Clique sozusagen, die seit Jahren bei Juve ist und die seit Jahren halt auch die anderen sozusagen mit aufnimmt, genau. Und wenn man das Ganze sportlich von hinten raus, dann ist auf jeden Fall Kedira, ist im Mittelfeld, jetzt unfassbar wichtig geworden, eben auch noch mehr eben seit dem Abgang von Pirlo. Und nach vorne sind eben klar, mit Higuain hast du jetzt, sag ich mal, diesen Mittelstürmer, von dem es vielleicht in seiner Kategorie noch 5, 6 im Weltfußball gibt. Viel mehr wird es, glaube ich, nicht geben, die einfach so eine Torquote über so lange Zeit vorweisen können. Und logischerweise, aber auf ihn werden wir auch noch zu sprechen kommen, die so Paulo Dybala ist logischerweise auch auf einem Weg, den vielleicht sich auch viele gerade im Ausland bis vor einem Jahr oder so auch nicht unbedingt vorstellen konnten.
Ja, lass da gerne gleich drüber sprechen. Was macht denn Paulo Dybala so stark? Also ich glaube, jeder der Hörerinnen und Hörer hat mindestens in der Champions League ein paar tolle Spiele von ihm gesehen. Woher kommt der? Was macht ihn aus? Und wird das so der nächste Kracher, den Juve dann irgendwann für teuer Geld verkaufen wird?
Also der erste Teil deiner Aussage auf jeden Fall, also der hat jetzt wirklich diese Saison nochmal einen unfassbar größeren Schritt gemacht. Also es ist ganz nette Geschichte, vor zwei Jahren als Juve zum letzten Mal im Champions League-Finale stand, saß er in Berlin auf der Tribüne, weil er gerade neu verpflichtet wurde. Deswegen ist er auch so ein bisschen dieses Gesicht dieses, was ist in diesen zwei Jahren passiert, warum sind die jetzt zwei Jahre später wieder im Finale und warum sagen jetzt ein Spieler wie Akellini, der Unterschied ist ganz einfach, 2015 waren wir selbst etwas überrascht, dass wir dahin gekommen sind und damals war Barca noch etwas als die Übermannschaft, also die waren da krasse Außenseite und haben das auch so ein bisschen gespürt. Und jetzt aber sagt er, jetzt ist ganz einfach, zwei Jahre später, jetzt wissen wir, was wir können und wir kennen unsere Stärken. Und das ist so ein bisschen der mentale Unterschied eben auch zu dem Finale vor zwei Jahren. Und Dybala zeichnet diesen Werdegang von Juve in diesen Jahren eigentlich ganz gut nach, weil Dybala kam als sehr junger Spieler aus Argentinien direkt nach Palermo, also in die Serie A, nach Italien. Und hat da einfach, Juve hat damals ja über 30 Millionen für den ausgegeben, wo damals glaube ich viele gesagt haben, ja, da ist es, warum 30 Millionen, aber der hat jetzt wirklich, Marotte hat das auch ganz gut gesagt, der hat jetzt den Schritt gemacht zu einem kompletten Spieler. Also es ist im Prinzip egal, ob du mit dem vorne in der Angriffsreihe über links kommst, über rechts kommst, übers Zentrum kommst als hängende Spitze. Der hat einfach unfassbaren Zug zum Tor, deswegen ist es auch seine Rolle ist schwer zu definieren. Also er ist eigentlich ein Stürmer, ein klassischer zweiter Stürmer, kann aber wie gesagt auch technisch von außen kommen, aus dem Zentrum hängen kommen. Und ich fand eben, wie du auch gesagt hast, gerade wenn man sich die Champions League Spiele angeschaut hat, hat man schon gesehen eine unfassbare Ballsicherheit, ein sehr gutes Auge auch für einen Mitspieler und in dem Fall dann wirklich ein kompletter technisch starker Angreifer. Und dieses Komplett, das sagen eben viele bei Juve, der hat jetzt wirklich den Schritt geschafft zu einem kompletten Offensivspieler und ist immer noch wahnsinnig jung. Klar wird er in Argentinien mittlerweile mit Messe verglichen. Diese Geschichten werden kommen von alleine. Ich glaube, das ist jetzt auch nicht unbedingt sein Anspruch, dass er damit verglichen wird. Aber was eben aus Turin zu hören ist, ist auch – und das passt wiederum auch sehr, sehr gut zu Juve – der soll ein sehr bodenständiger Junge sein, ein sehr fleißiger Junge, ein sehr zielstrebiger. Also in keinster Weise so ein 20-Jähriger, der jetzt einfach großartig spielt, aber so keine Ahnung, was sonst im Kopf hat. Und von dem her passt er wirklich wunderbar zu Juve, weil er auch immer wieder betont, auch jetzt für mich ist da immer noch viel zu machen und ich sehe meinen Weg noch lange nicht zu Ende. Und deswegen war der erste Teil ja, Juve hat ihn sich jetzt ja auch mit der Vertragsverlängerung gesichert, aber – und das ist wiederum, deswegen passt er wiederum sehr schön in die Geschichte rein – Juve hat in keinster Weise vor, ihn jetzt erstmal vielleicht so a la Pogba in den nächsten Jahren zu viel Geld zu machen. Also der Plan ist, dass der bleibt und dass der jetzt erstmal auch die nächsten Jahre das ganze Ding da vorne drin rockt. Wir brauchen nicht um den heißen Brei herum reden, keine Ahnung, was ist, wenn in einem Jahr jemand 150 Millionen Euro auf den Tisch legt. Klar, darüber kann man jetzt müßig zu diskutieren, aber das Bestreben ist schon da, weil anders als bei Pogba, da hat man schon immer so ein bisschen gemerkt, vielleicht auch ein bisschen durch das schwierige Verhältnis mit Mino Raiola, seinem Berater, weil man immer wusste, ja, keine Ahnung, wenn der vielleicht dann wirklich das ganz, ganz große Geld sieht, dann machen wir den einfach auch zu Geld. Und das merkt man momentan bei die Baller nicht. Also Juwe ist jetzt schon so gepolt, dass sie sagen, wir wollen mit dieser Truppe, die wir jetzt haben und mit diesem Generationswechsel, den wir Schritt für Schritt eingeleitet haben, wollen wir auch die nächsten Jahre da ganz, ganz vorne mitspielen.
Punkt. Wenn ich mir die Saison von Juwe anschaue, dann sehe ich in der Champions League keine einzige Niederlage und Gegner wie Barca und Monaco wegräumt im Viertelfinale und der Halbfinale. Ich sehe in der Serie A, wenn ich mich jetzt gerade nicht erzähle, vier Niederlagen, wobei eine schon bedeutungslos gewesen sein dürfte, hinten raus. Ich sehe eine Niederlage im Supercoppa-Finale, dem italienischen Supercup, und eine Niederlage im Rückspiel der Coppa Italia gegen Neapel im Halbfinale. Das heißt nicht allzu viel. Was spielt denn Juventus für einen Fußball, das in allen Wettbewerben so gut funktioniert und vor allem dann auch in der Champions League?
Ich möchte ganz mit einer kleinen Klammer anfangen. Andrea Barzali, der Ex-Wolfsburger, hat das nämlich vor kurzem ganz gut auf den Punkt gebracht. Bei Juve ist ja oft die Rede, man hört das ja, wenn man über den FC Bayern spricht, das Mir San Mia, das Bayern gehen oder zum Beispiel bei anderen großen Vereinen. Und bei Juve ist das wirklich, ich sage mal so, das ist in der DNA sehr verankert. Barzali hat es eben sehr gut gesagt. Er hat gemeint, wenn du zu Juve kommst, dann spürst du vom ersten Tag, ohne dass dir irgendjemand im Verein da was sagt, das hier einfach nur ums Gewinnen geht. Hier geht es darum, das Spiel zu gewinnen. Da braucht man gar nicht lange drum rum reden, da brauchen wir nicht, aber wir haben es zweimal nicht verloren. Das spielt alles keine Rolle. Es gibt ja diese nette kleine Geschichte, so wie wir die Bayern – das ist mir, sein, mir – im Kragen eingesteckt haben, hat Juve einen Spruch von seinem Ehrenpräsidenten drin, der heißt, Gewinnen ist nicht das Wichtigste, es ist das Einzige, das zählt. Das steht bei Juve hinten oben im Kragen. Und das sind wirklich, also dieser Verein, gerade auch in den letzten Jahren, das hat er sich halt wiedererarbeitet nach den Turbulenzen davor, steht einfach in Italien wie kein anderer für diesen unbedingten Siegeswille und dieses unbedingte immer weiter. Man könnte ja auch sagen, jetzt sind wir dreimal Meister geworden, schön, ja. Die wären es zum vierten Mal, die wären es zum fünften Mal, die wären es zum sechsten Mal. Und das muss man vielleicht einfach als kleine Klammer mal kurz vorne dran anstellen. Zum Sportlichen ist es definitiv so, und da muss man dann logischerweise auch kurz auf Massimiliano Allegri, auf den Trainer, zu sprechen kommen. Man hatte gesehen, als Conte weg war, dachte man, oh mein Gott, was macht Juve jetzt? Conte hat Juve zu dem gemacht, was es ist. Und welche Rolle Conte als Trainer spielt, hat man jetzt in den letzten ein, zwei Jahren ja auch international gesehen. Da waren auch einige, ja, wie geht es weiter? Aber man hat einfach gemerkt, dass auch Conte, der Conte einfach auf einen Stamm, diesen Spielerstamm zählt, der allein schon eine wahnsinnige Qualität mitbringt. Und Alegre war sehr clever, sehr intelligent, hat erst mal sozusagen diese Stärke, die Conte dann auch mit seinem System implementiert hat, erst mal so weitergeführt, hat nicht gleich einfach seine Ideen, sozusagen der Mannschaft aufgezwungen, sondern hat die erst mal aus ihrer Stärke heraus allein, sozusagen vom Taktischen her, das weiterführen lassen, hat dann aber peu à peu seine Ideen sozusagen eingeinfließen lassen. Und muss man jetzt in dieser Saison wirklich sagen, die Idee von ihm, weil er hat wirklich lange auch noch das 3-5-2, das konnte er ja einfach so, ja, reingepresst hat, sozusagen immer wieder das spielen lassen, weil er wusste, das kann die Mannschaft blind. Aber eben vor ein paar Monaten, es war ungefähr im Dezember, hat er angefangen, dieses 4-2-3-1 zu implementieren, mit insgesamt fünf Offensiven eben auf dem Platz, wo eben Higuin ganz vorne, dann Diwala zentral dahinter, links Manzukic, rechts Quadrado und als einer der zwei Sechsen in Khedira Pjanic, der eigentlich auch als Offensiver daherkommt. Und da war am Anfang der Aufschrei sehr groß, da dachten viele Italien, oh, das mag in Italien funktionieren, aber wenn du damit in die Champions League gehst, dann wird das nichts. Und die Mannschaft hat aber gezeigt, oder auch der Trainer, dass sie das so einstudiert haben oder so perfektioniert haben, dass das eben auch international funktioniert. Und Juve jetzt eben nicht mehr diese Mannschaft ist, die nur auf sich, auf seine Defensive verlässt und dann vorne vielleicht so wie damals mit Morata, mit Vidal auch einfach Nadelstiche setzt, sondern Juve ist jetzt mittlerweile eine Mannschaft, die den Spiel auch auf europäischer Bühne dominieren kann, was man teilweise gegen Barca, gegen Himmelspiel gesehen hat. Und dieser Schritt, glaube ich, war auch sehr wichtig für die Mannschaft, weil, wie wir schon gesagt haben, da sind sehr viele schon sehr lang dabei, da sind sehr viele schon sehr erfolgreich, haben alles gewonnen eigentlich, was es national zu gewinnen gibt. Die brauchten vielleicht auch so eine kleine neue Stimulanz, eine kleine neue Motivation. Und das hat Allegra auf jeden Fall mit diesem offensiven System hinbekommen.
Das letzte Mal Champions League-Sieger wurde man 95, 96 gegen Ajax. Das ist also auch schon 21 Jahre her, seitdem vier Finals verloren, direkt in den Jahren danach gegen Dortmund. Daran erinnern sich die deutschen Fußballfans wahrscheinlich noch am besten. Und im Jahr danach gegen Real Madrid, dann gegen Milan im Elfmeterschießen. Das war ein für den neutralen Zuschauer schwer zu erträgen, das Champions League-Finale 2002, 2003. Und jetzt eben gegen Barca in Berlin 2014, 2015. Was bedeutet denn jetzt das Champions League-Finale, wenn wir ein bisschen vorausblicken, auf den Samstag? Ist diese Historie ein Thema, wenn es darum geht, da raufzuschauen? Hat man da die Sorge, wenn da jetzt schon wieder ein Finale verloren geht, dann schafft man es irgendwie nicht, das zu vergolden, was man sich aufgebaut hat?
Das ist auch eine ganz interessante Art und Weise, wie das momentan gelebt wird. Zum Beispiel vor zwei Jahren war diese Statistik omnipräsent in Italien. Juve eben so viele Finale gespielt, so viele verloren. Dieses bisschen Negative rundherum war sehr präsent. Momentan ist das nicht wirklich präsent. Klar, kennt man die Statistik und daran hat sich ja seit dem letzten Finale nichts geändert. Im Gegenteil, es ist noch ein verlorenes Finale dazugekommen. Und klar, man braucht ja auch nicht lange mit einem heißen Brei herumreden. Juve wird zwar momentan international sehr – ich höre das sehr oft – das heißt, dieses Jahr ist Juve dran, Juve macht es. Ich denke dann immer nur, ja, Atletico war eigentlich auch zweimal dran gegen Real. Hat es auch nicht einmal geschafft. Und die Konstellation kennen wir, einmal Nachspielzeit, einmal Elfmeterschießen. Also ich glaube, Real ist es relativ wurscht, dass da eine Mannschaft ist, wo viele sagen, ja, das wäre jetzt die Krönung und eben sozusagen genau dieser Peak, auf den sie sehr lange hingearbeitet haben. Also Real ist und bleibt, finde ich, Favorit einfach allein darum, dass dies zum dritten Mal im Vierjahrenfinale stehen und die letzten zwei gewonnen haben. Das ist relativ simpel. Da geht es jetzt gar nicht darum, da die Außenseiterrolle irgendwie für sich zu beanspruchen. Aber eben, man merkt, wie gesagt, man merkt es in den Aussagen der Spieler. Man merkt es in kleinen Gesten. Vielleicht, ich weiß nicht, vielleicht erinnerst du dich noch, es gibt diese Szene aus dem Rückspiel in Barcelona, wo in der 88. Minute im Rückspiel beim 0-0, wo Nucci vor einem Eckball kurz zu Messi hingegangen ist und ihn einfach gefragt hat, ob es danach mit dem Trikot klappt. Und Chiellini hat das gesehen und hat ihm quasi so einen ziemlich deutlichen Klaps auf dem Unterarm gegeben, um ihm zu signalisieren, hey Junge, jetzt spielen wir noch die 5 Minuten und danach kannst du machen, was du magst. Also nur um zu sagen, die Spieler sind so in diesem Tunnel drin, dass sie wissen, sie können es auch sportlich schaffen. Garantie gibt es keine, ist ja klar, das ist ein Finale, 50-50, kann alles passieren. Aber diese, sag ich mal, manchmal Negativität, die solche Mannschaften auch entgibt, ist momentan eigentlich bei Juventus nicht zu spüren, sondern die sind sehr, sehr fokussiert, sie wissen, dass sie es drauf haben. Und auf deinen letzten Teil einer Frage, klar wäre das jetzt, ich glaube die Enttäuschung wäre diesmal viel größer als eben als vor zwei Jahren. Keine Frage, was jetzt nicht am Finalgegner liegt, sondern einfach an der eigenen Stärke. Aber selbst wenn die das verlieren sollten am Samstag, bin ich mir sicher, dass die im nächsten Jahr und auch in den nächsten zwei Jahren ganz sicher wieder ganz vorne mitspielen werden in der Champions League, weil sie jetzt mittlerweile einfach diese Selbstüberzeugung haben und wissen, wir haben nicht nur die Erfahrung, sondern wir haben jetzt auch die spielerischen Qualität oder die spielerischen Mittel, um einfach auf höchster Ebene auch mit Bayern, mit Real, mit Barca mithalten zu können. Und von dem her glaube ich nicht, dass das ein riesen psychologischer Knick wäre. Es wäre eine riesen Enttäuschung, da braucht man gar nicht drüber reden, aber ich glaube nicht, dass die Juve-Welt dadurch zusammenbrechen würde.
Das ist schon wirklich faszinierend, auch wenn man sich nochmal vor Augen führt, welche Leistungen Juve bisher auf den Platz gebracht hat. Es gibt ja nur sechs Vereine, die es in der langen Geschichte des Europa, des Landesmeistercups und der Champions League es geschafft haben, das Trippel zu holen mit eben genau jedem Titel. Das waren Barca 14-15, Bayern 12-13 und Inter 2009-2010. Und dann müssen wir schon weiter zurückgehen. Manchester United 98-99, Ajax Amsterdam 71-72. Und, das hatte ich nicht mehr auf dem Zettel, ehrlich gesagt, ZDGlasco 1966-67. Das sind die einzigen sechs Teams, die es geschafft haben, ihre nationale Liga zu gewinnen, ihren nationalen Pokal zu gewinnen und den Landesmeistercup oder den Champions League-Pokal zu gewinnen. Und da könnte sich jetzt Juve einreihen. Real übrigens nicht, die sind in der Copa del Rey ausgeschieden im Viertelfinale. Das ist schon, das verdeutlicht einem schon nochmal, dass man es hier mit einer, mit einer, ja, goldene Generation finde ich ein bisschen, das meint eigentlich nur so junge Spieler, aber wir haben es hier mit einer, einer der besten Turiner Mannschaften zu tun, die es jemals gab und das nach Pirlo. Das finde ich so krass. Also, man konnte sich irgendwie nicht vorstellen, Juve ohne Pirlo und ohne Vidal. Da fehlt der feine Fuß und da fehlt der Holzfuß. Und dann ist auch noch Pogba gegangen. Da fehlt so ein bisschen der Fixpunkt und das Ego. Und in dieser Saison danach kommt man so weit. Das ist wirklich herausragend. Und fast ein bisschen geht mir fast ein bisschen unter, ehrlich gesagt, in der deutschen Sportberichterstattung. Ist halt nicht so der Fokus drauf.
Ja, und eben wie gesagt, es ist vielleicht eben wirklich das, was wir versucht haben, eben rauszuarbeiten, dass es eben klar sind, es einzeln, wenn die die Riesenrolle spielen, ist ja klar. Ich bin mir zum Beispiel ganz sicher, dass wenn Buffon irgendwann aufhört, und irgendwann wird auch Buffon aufhören, obwohl es wahrscheinlich für einige schwer vorstellbar ist.
Aber wenn sie es gewinnen, dann hört er doch direkt auf, oder?
Nee, das macht er eben nicht, weil er hat schon gesagt, er spielt auf jeden Fall noch die Wärme in Russland. Also das ist es eben. Geil. Auch wenn die das Ding am Samstag holen, der wird nicht aufhören, genau. Aber logisch, irgendwann wird es vorbei sein. Und da glaube ich zum Beispiel, dass das von der Mannschaftsführung her oder von, wie soll man es sagen, von der Stabilität in der Kabine der noch größere Einschnitt wird als bei Pirlo. Weil, wie gesagt, bei Pirlo war Buffon noch da, die haben das zu zweit teilweise. Logisch Pirlo auch auf eine ganz andere Art und Weise, mit seiner ruhigen Art und so. Aber wenn Buffon weg ist, dann gibt es jetzt logischerweise, nicht falsch verstehen, es gibt auch ohne ihn dieses Rückkehr, dieses Bonucci, Marchesio, Barzali, Chiellini. Also das wird auch nicht zusammenbrechen. Aber ich glaube, und das hört man jetzt auch schon durch, dass einfach da dann wirklich dieses ganz, ganz große Lieder-Ding gehen wird. Und deswegen bin ich sehr gespannt, wer dann auch in den Jahren danach im Juventor stehen wird, weil ich glaube, egal wer da kommt, erstmal wird das alles andere als einfach. Und nicht aus sportlichen, nicht primär aus sportlichen Gesichtspunkten, sondern ich glaube mehr einfach durch die Art und Weise, was da für eine Rolle auch in der Kabine spielt. Aber eben gesagt, deswegen, wenn man das kurz weglässt, es sind Einzelne und klar sind das wirklich wichtige Spieler, aber es ist halt einfach dieser Spirit, der den Verein und in dem Moment dann auch die Spieler ausmacht. Und ein Symbol dafür, haben wir jetzt noch gar nicht genannt, ist Mario Mandzukic. Weil, ich glaube, wer hätte das gedacht, bis vor einem Jahr, klar, jeder kannte Mandzukic, kantiger Mittelstürmer, wichtig auch nach hinten. Und jetzt pflügt der plötzlich da auf links rauf und runter. Das, glaube ich, musst du einem Spieler auch erstmal dann klarmachen, dass das seine neue Rolle ist. Aber eben, wenn du es schaffst, dass du eine Mannschaft dahinter hast, und er merkt, hoppala, ich bin ja in der Rolle auch unfassbar wichtig, und du einen Trainer hast, der das überhaupt erstmal erkennt, weil ich weiß nicht, wie viele Trainer es eben gibt, die vielleicht aus einem Mittelstürmer einen links außen machen, der auch am eigenen Strafraum-Eck sozusagen seine Aufgabe erledigt. Das ist ein sehr gutes Bild dafür auch, dass die da sozusagen wirklich, das hört man auch oft, aber diese Juve-Mannschaft, diese Saison hat es definitiv geschafft, dass kein einziger Spieler über der Mannschaft sozusagen steht. Und auch da noch eine kleine Anekdote, ich glaube, die ist in Deutschland auch relativ untergegangen. Im Achtelfinale, vor dem Achtelfinale-Rückspiel gegen Porto, wo Juve noch bei Weitem nicht durch war oder wo sehr wichtig einfach war, da war auch noch diese Stärke, diese Nominanz noch nicht da, da hat Allegri Bonucci auf die Tribüne verbannt, weil der im Spiel davor ihn nach einer Auswechslung, sagen wir mal, nicht sehr freundlich begegnet ist. Und da haben sehr viele gezittert, Bonucci ist der wichtigste Abwehrmann, weil er einfach die Abwehr leitet. Und wenn das schiefgegangen wäre, das wäre Allegri um die Ohren geflogen. Da braucht man gar nicht drum reden. Aber mit diesem Signal im Nachhinein hat er halt gezeigt, schaut mal her, bei mir steht keiner über den anderen, auch wenn es ein sehr, sehr wichtiger Spieler ist. Und ich glaube, das war auch so eine kleine Geschichte, wo der Verein nach außen Stärke demonstriert hat und die Mannschaft gemerkt hat, ja, schaut mal her, alle zusammen, aber nicht einer allein und einer mit seinem Ego, sondern wir machen das als Mannschaft. Das sind vielleicht so kleine Geschichten, die einfach zeigen, das wird vom Verein vorgelebt und irgendwie kommt das wirklich auch in die Kabine rein und kommt in die Köpfe vieler Spieler auch rein, die da hinkommen sozusagen.
Die Parallelen sind wirklich unübersehbar, auch die Parallelen, dass du eine Mannschaft hast, die die heimische Liga dominiert, zwar vom Punktevorsprung her nicht so krass wie die Bayern in dieser Saison und so oft zuvor, es waren nur vier Pünktchen vor der Roma, die Juve zum Titel gereicht haben, aber eben zum sechsten Mal in Folge nationaler Meister geworden, zum dritten Mal in Folge den Pokal geholt, insgesamt 33 italienische Meisterschaften. Wir haben in der Schlusskonferenz, in der letzten, zum 34. Spieltag, eine Diskussion darüber geführt, ob der FC Bayern seiner nationalen Liga entwachsen ist und alles darauf hindeutet, dass es irgendwann mal eine europäische Liga geben muss. Wie ist denn das in Turin? Ist die Gemengelage da ähnlich? Oder verkürzt und populistisch gefragt, wie viele Turiner treffe ich noch auf der Straße nach einer gewonnenen Meisterschaft?
Also es ist, du hast es ja schon gesagt, genau, Hubert, es hat jetzt sozusagen einen Serientitelvorsprung auf die Bayern, genau. Ja, in den letzten Jahren war die Dominanz in Italien einfach frappierend. Also da könnte man auch weiter ausholen. Das liegt ja nicht nur daran, dass Juve sportlich gut arbeitet, sondern da spielt logisch auch mit rein. Juve ist ja immer noch der einzige Großverein Italienische, der sein eigenes Stadion mittlerweile hat, der einfach mehr Geld generiert und der einfach dieses Geld, das sie zur Verfügung haben, einfach, ja, einfach auch besser einsetzt als viele andere. Und auch da passt es wieder ganz gut rein, zum Beispiel Pjanic und Figuain, die geholt wurden. Das waren, das sind nicht nur sehr gute Spieler, qualitativ, sondern die haben, das hat Bad Salja auch vor kurzem gesagt, die haben diesen Hunger gebracht nach Titeln, weil die hatten zum Beispiel beide noch keine Scudetto gewonnen. Die sind zwar auch schon seit Jahren sehr international auch renommierte Spieler, aber die hatten halt sozusagen auch wirklich noch diesen Hunger sozusagen, um nochmal nach was zu greifen. Das nur als kleine Klammer. Die Dominanz ist, ja, wobei auch Napoli diese Saison, auch die Roma hat, es vergessen viele, die Roma hat 87 Punkte gemacht und Neapel 86. Also ich sag mal so, wenn es dieses ausredische Juve nicht gäbe, dann mit solchen Punktezahlen wird man locker Meister in solchen Ligen eben, in anderen Konstellationen. Es ist aber schon so eben, wie gesagt, Juve hat sich einfach sowohl wirtschaftlich als eben auch vom Renommee her einfach in Italien, ja, über Jahre jetzt diesen Status erarbeitet, dass ich glaube, dass es ja so ähnlich – ich sehe es in Deutschland schon noch krasser, muss ich sagen, weil, wie gesagt, man sieht es ja dieses Jahr. Eigentlich ist mit Dortmund unter Anführungszeichen nur ein Konkurrent da, aber bei dem muss halt auch alles passen, dass die vorne rüber können. In Italien, wie gesagt, Neapel macht es sehr, sehr gut. Neapel hat man vielleicht auch in der Champions League gesehen. Die haben drei Halbzeiten von vier gegen Real auch sehr gut mitgehalten. Also auch international das Ding, logisch nicht auf einer Stufe wie Juve, aber darunter können die mit sehr vielen Mannschaften auch hochklassig mithalten. Die Roma ist ein Fall für sich. Da könnte man eine Sendung alleine auch drüber machen, weil diese Stadt ist einfach die Erwartungshaltung und das ist ein sehr komplizierter Standort. Aber ich glaube auch, dass in den nächsten Jahren, wenn Juve es nicht von selbst, von alleine liegen lässt, die auch weiter auf jeden Fall immer die 1A-Option sein werden in Italien. Diese Diskussion über die Europäische Liga ist in Italien nicht so groß, weil schon auch da die Hoffnung da ist, dass jetzt mit Milan und Inter, wo es die letzten Jahre turbulent ist und noch viel zu wenig zuging, vielleicht auch wieder durch das Fremde-Investment Schritt für Schritt nach oben geht. Also in Italien ist in der Höhe oben vielleicht die Dichte schon ein bisschen kompakter, wobei Juventus, da brauchen wir nicht drumherum reden, einfach definitiv nochmal eine Stufe über allen anderen steht. Kleine Frage.
Ach, es ist so faszinierend. Wir könnten noch über Sophia sprechen. Christian, irgendwann musst du mir auch nochmal erklären. Es gibt Mafia-Probleme, das ist natürlich ein Klischee, aber es trifft zu. Es kam jetzt heraus, dass es da Ticketdeals gab von einem bekannten Mafiosi, der eventuell mit dem Club auf eine Art und Weise zusammengearbeitet hat. Wissentlich oder unwissentlich gibt es gerade einen laufenden Prozess. Ziemlich kompliziert, aber auch sehr interessant, sich da einzulesen. Du hast ja schon kurz angedeutet Milan, Roma usw. Bei Milan könnten wir über chinesische Besitzer sprechen und bei der Roma über Francesco Totti. Das wäre auch ein schönes Thema. Ich glaube, Christian, wir müssen häufiger über die Serie A sprechen, vielleicht auch mal ein Tribütengespräch machen. Da hätte ich große Lust zu. Das ist einfach eine interessante Liga.
Sehr gerne. Wir haben es jetzt ja selbst gerade gemerkt. Man kommt ja manchmal dann im Gespräch auf viele andere interessante Aspekte. Und wie gesagt, jederzeit können wir es sehr gerne machen. Und würde ich mich auch sehr darüber freuen.
Ich danke sehr. Christian Bernhard, freier Sportjournalist. Er liest bei Twitter nur mit. Er ist selber nicht aktiv, liebe Leute. Da müsst ihr jetzt durch. Ihr könnt ihm leider nicht folgen. Christian, ich danke dir sehr. Und du hast mir große Vorfreude jetzt aufs Champions League-Finale bereitet. Das hätte ich, ehrlich gesagt, fast nicht mehr erwartet, dass es noch gibt. Ja, und wir, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, hören uns auch bald, nämlich im nächsten Rasenfunk. Bis dahin, macht's gut.